يزور رئيس بوتين شبه جزيره القرم في
الذكرى التاسعه لضمها من قبل روسيا هي ارض
روسيه بالنسبه له وبالنسبه للكثير من
الروس الذين يتذكرون استرجاعها في نهايه
القرن الثامن عشر بالنسبه لهم ضموا شبه
جزيره القرم في مارس 2014 مجرد استرجاع
اخر لارض روسيه استفادت موسكو من ثلاثه
عوامل ضم القرم عام 2014 التوتر وعدم
الاستقرار في اوكرانيا بعد ثوره الميدان
والتركيبه السكانيه لشبه الجزيره التي
يشكل الروس اكثر من نصفها ووجود مقر اسطول
البحر الاسود الروسي في عاصمتها
بموجب اتفاق سابق مع اوكرانيا ما لوحظ بعد
الضم ان رد الفعل الغربي لم يكن بالحده
التي تعرقل تنفيذ بوسين مخططاته في شبه
الجزيره لتنفيذ هذه المخططات كانت هناك
حاجه ماسه لربط مادي بين القرم وروسيا
فجاء تدشينو جسر كاش عام
عشر يبلغ طول الجسر 19 كلم وهو الاطول في
اوروبا وكلف اربعه مليارات دولار عندما
بدات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا في فبراير
العمل الماضي عاد الاهتمام الى شبه جزيره
القرم يقول خبراء عسكريون ان من اهم اسباب
هذه الحرب ضمانه تزويد شبه جزيره القرم
بالمياه من نهر دنيبر جزء من العمليات
العسكريه انطلقت من شبه الجزيره التي توجد
بها عده قواعد عسكريه روسيه بعد اشهر من
بدء الحرب بدات اوكرانيا تستهدف هذه
القواعد وعلى راسها مقر اسطول البحر
الاسود الروسي بسيفاستوبول ثم جاءت الضربه
الاكبر وهي استهداف جسر كيرش في اكتوبر من
السنه الماضيه كان استهداف الجسر رساله
اوكرانيه رافقها تحول في الموقف السياسي
من القرم في كييف
ففي بدايه الحرب كان الرئيس الاوكراني
يبدي مرونه بشان شبه الجزيره حتى انه
اقترح تاجيل البث في مصيرها خمسه عشر عاما
لكنه غير موقفه بعد التحولات التي شهدت
المعارك واخفاق الروس في تحقيق مكاسب
كبيره اصبح زينتكي يطالب باسترجاع القرم
وبدا مساعدوه يتحدثون عن قدره قواتهم على
استرجاعها بقوه السلاح لم يشاطر حماسته
وتسرب على اللقاءاته مع المسؤولين
الامريكيين انهم دعوه لتقديم مطالب
عقلانيه تساعد على فتح مسار الدبلوماسيه
من جديد